les quatre mousquetaires sont avec nous
ce soir en commençant par gérard
depardieu porthos alors vous êtes chez
bonsoir messieurs et 4 mousquetaires
ressemble tenait main peu aux sept
mercenaires il ya un côté western dans
ce film gérard c'est bien c'est
d'ailleurs ça qui est agréable
en plus les sternes part d'humain revu
et corrigé par andy wallace avec des
amis et des acteurs de cette trempe à
leur banque
c'est vrai que on est en moi j'ai été
très heureux est-ce que vous foncez vous
avez eu quelques surprises avec
l'interprétation de l'histoire de france
par les américains pendant le tournage
qui téléphonent au bout vous virard
depardieu a pas du tout mais vous avez
je je je crois que l'histoire qu'on
raconte je ne sais rien moi l'amour
savage la prospection de l'histoire de
france
je ne faisais pas vécu je pense pas été
beaucoup d'historiens qui ai vécu cette
chose je vous admire alexandre dumas
d'avoir fait de l'histoire des histoires
ça c'est vraiment joli quoi jimmy
rollins vous jouez vous le rôle
d'aramits on a vu dans ce film il ya
cinq stars ajoutons que dicaprio
lorsqu'on est un iftar entend baisse que
l'on a forcément un tournage très très
facile ou est-ce que c'est compliqué
j'ai cru il n'a rien entendu et je
prendrai un problème de micro bien je
repose ma question dit rémy aron vous
jouez donc le rôle d'aramide lorsqu'on
met cinq stars enfants baisse que un
réalisateur a beaucoup de problèmes de
tournage est ce que le tournage a été
facile est ce que vous êtes bien amusé
oui cet été oui en fait on était entre
des amis des gens que j'admire et j'aime
bien travailler avec ces pauses acteurs
les meilleurs qui soient
je sais c'était un grand plaisir au
travail avec léo qui est quatre ou de
talent fut sa jeunesse qui troppo plus
haché nes mais c'était quand même bien
d'être travaillé avec nous bien il berne
moment donné vous êtes vous le
d'artagnan
vous savez que les français vont
beaucoup vous en vouloir car nous dans
notre histoire de france d'artagnan est
un très honnête homme est là d'une
certaine façon c'est le traître de
l'amande le traître je sais pas si je
crois c'était pas ça du tout pourquoi
les chinois nous reste quelques
inquiétudes elle était là sans droit
créées à ses amis il est perçu et
d'achat en fait au déroulement de
l'histoire convoi qui n'a pas l'âme d'un
traître
au contraire il est courageux alors 2008
vous vous êtes à tous dans le dans le
film vous êtes le quatrième mousquetaire
est-ce que vous connaissiez à rentrer ce
film est ce que vous connaissiez ce
roman d'alexandre dumas est ce que vous
connaissez les aventures des quatre
mousquetaires
ouais ouais je lis que le siège réservé
lui il ya très longtemps quan mais
j'étais le groupe est jeune mais elle
gérard depardieu revient à vous est ce
que vous vous avez des problèmes pour
tourner c'est un film que j'avais tourné
en anglais c'était un problème pour vous
bien ça s'est passé très facilement voir
ce n'est pas assez facilement
j'ai compris demandé si je comprends ou
pas
pour me dit action jb avec jeux du
moment que je voyais dans le regard de
mes amis une compréhension
j'étais heureux leur dernier show gérard
si on doit parler tout à leur génie et
c'est un peu un western
est-ce que vous qualifieriez de films
historiques ou film d' aventure
kim d'aventura film beau divertissement
un film qui émeut qui fait rire et puis
qui peut nous raconter qui veut le
montrer ce que pouvait être
éventuellement le l'histoire d'un roi
d'histoire des mousquetaires c'est un
film où c'est à cet âge au lit film vous
allez tourner avec leonardo dicaprio
c'est actuellement la grande vedette
après le succès du titanic ç'a été un
partenaire très très très agréable est
ce que vous pensez que c'est un très
grand acteur en devenir ou déjà un
crayon khôl
c'est déjà un très grand acteur je pense
qu'il avait fait déjà ses preuves avant
dans d'autres films avant le titanic
et c'est vrai que tous ici reconnaissent
le talent de leurs deux du cabrio en
plus il est nos aînés les jeunes c'est
un quelqu'un d'extrêmement professionnel
il est très riche aussi un mais je n'ai
pas jaloux aucun d'entre vous non non la
jalousie est pas c'est pas chez les
mousquetaires regardez vos pages dont
j'avais jaloux oscillé alors que je
voudrais simplement gérard puisque vous
m'entendez parfaitement que vous répétez
puissent ensemble célèbre formule des
mousquetaires alors un pour tous tous
pour un
on va être là tous pour un un pour tous
tous pour un messieurs émotions ça vous
merci merci d'avoir été notre ami bon
soir